Lewis Hamilton is one of Formula One's
greats his fourth World Championship
makes in the most successful British
driver of all time an amazing
achievement for a boyfriend Stevenage
but somehow it seems the British public
has not taken Hamilton to their heart
why is that what does it mean for his
brand and his potential to make money
well I can ask the chief executive M&C
Saatchi Sport Steve Martin who joins me
now live from Johannesburg so Steve good
evening to you why is it that people
don't love Lewis Hamilton in the way
they PAP should do I don't know he's
he's a pretty divisive character I mean
you can't argue what he does on the
track I mean it's an extraordinary fate
to win the fourth word tidal he's won 62
races I mean he's 91 pole position so
what he's done is second-to-none
certainly from a British point of view
you know when he's a world superstar so
everything should add up that actually
everything he does off the track should
make him as appealing but but it sort of
doesn't work like that it I think when
you look at Lewis he's so professional
when we've been privileged to work with
him on a few brands in the past and he
is super professional I mean he turns up
on time he does everything with good
grace he really is slick from that point
of view but there's something that is a
bit almost confused from a brand
perspective and you know maybe that's
whether it's his fashion choices or just
some of those petulance maybe that comes
across every now and again that seems to
dilute all all the good stuff he does on
the track so it's from a brand
perspective is pretty confused lives in
Monaco perhaps no I don't think so I
mean I think we we're sort of beyond
that these are global superstars now I
think people realize that you know some
of the biggest stars don't have to live
on our shores I mean the way footballs
go on the biggest stars are Messi and
Ronaldo they don't play even in the
Premier League so I think we're beyond
that and you know the American sports
stars whether it's you know the Tiger
Woods you're LeBron James are the words
that you know they're not necessarily
touchable and they don't have to live in
your own backyard but they're incredibly
aspirational I think it's
some of the parts with Louis they can
come across sometimes as a bit forced I
think I think certainly there looks like
he's trying to force an image even
though that he you know really with the
success he sallied you'd be very
comfortable in his own skin from from
our point of view so I don't know I
certainly don't think it's because he
lives off the shores if you like that
should make any difference anymore do
you think it's affected his earnings
power state briefly not really I mean
he's in superstar league again from
earnings potential particularly of his
contact with with Mercedes McLaren
Mercedes is extraordinary you know and
he's commercially very powerful he's got
big deals with L'Oreal and they've
Monster Energy and other brandies so EE
but he doesn't have the Rings that the
likes of David Beckham had even though
he's got you know five million Instagram
followers five million Twitter followers
doesn't translate a commercial success
either alright people stick Martin got
into them I'm afraid thanks for joining
me